you trippin
the okay is going did you stay on the
bar
what sort of a man are you
I don't know what you mean well he'll
vouch for the guy you'll give your word
on his character I take him here to my
dommage show him the path to becoming
free and landed man and now he has fled
the contract of his indenture leaving me
to suspect what lurks in your heart will
you flee or sink your axe into my skull
the moment I turned my back
no sir I will have you know if you
abandon our agreement like a combatant
okay I will wait to fold on your hide
the fair and proper punishment do your
Duke I'm a man of my word
you had better be tell me how around it
is no coincidence said okay took his
leave after bringing that curse around
you okay said nothing to me no I fear I
have loosed something into this world I
will soon regret okay
yeah a cunning creature who if he does
not find his death will prosper as Frog
to pond rat to rot
the clever decay will find his place in
Wapping took is afraid of the woods he
will get lost and die I'm sure of it
it will overcome that fear because he is
a rat and he will prosper with his teeth
and claws and never full belly I will
search again tomorrow
no you must return to your duties now if
I may prevail myself of your fire
just for a moment
[Music]